hey this is pressure Locker which of the
statements if any are false this is a
list of ten statements the nth statement
in this list claims that exactly n of
the statements are false can you figure
it out while you're working on that
problem also try and figure out this
variation it's the same list of ten
items except the word exactly is
replaced by the words at least give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution we'll get started with the list
that the end statement says that exactly
n statements are false consider the
tenth statement in this list if
statement ten is true that implies all
of the statements in the list are false
including statement ten this is a
contradiction which means statement ten
must be false so we know at least one of
the statements in this list is false how
many of the statements can be true at
the same time the statements in the list
are mutually exclusive you cannot have
exactly X statements be true and exactly
why statements be true for X not equal
to Y this implies at most one statement
can be true if one statement is true
that would mean nine statements are
false
so our candidate is we have nine false
statements and one true statement this
corresponds to the claim of statement
nine if statements one through eight and
ten are false and statement nine is true
that actually works out logically so
that's our answer
statement nine is true and statements
one through eight and statement ten are
false we have nine false statements and
one true statement now let's solve the
variation where the end statement says
at least n statements are false we'll
proceed similarly will consider the ten
statement if this is true that means all
statements in the list are false
including statement ten this again is a
contradiction so we know that statement
ten is false and that means at least one
statement must be false so if one
statement is false at least one
statement is false we know that the
first statement has to be true
now we proceed to the next statement if
statement 9 is true that would mean
statements 2 through 9 have to be false
because we already know statement 1 is
true therefore statement 9 has to be
false and that implies at least two
statements are false statement 9 and 10
are false so we know that statement 2 is
true we can similarly proceed to show
that statements 8 7 and 6 are false
while 3 4 and 5 must be true so what we
end up with is we have 5 possibly true
statements and five possibly false
statements and this turns out to
logically work so statements 1 through 5
are true and statement 6 through 10 are
false did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch from our blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch it on social media pressure Locker
and if you liked this video please check
out my books your links in the video
description